I'm Emily I'm a Staff engineer at Intuit
MailChimp uh that means I say it depends
a lot that's kind of my job uh mostly I
would rather be painting
um
I'm a big fan of this guy named Ryan
Curtin he's pretty cool and one of my
proudest engineering achievements is
that I'm a contributor to the Enterprise
fizzbuzz project which was really taking
like a comprehensive view about solving
the important business issues of today
so if you get bored during my talk you
can go check out Enterprise Fizz Buzz
Edition
um as a painter these are some of my
brushes
and I'm putting this picture up today
because
today as we're talking about testing I'm
gonna paint with a prod brush not with
the little ones and actually as a side
note there's a little oil painting
lesson for you all right here right now
in order to maintain kind of a painterly
aspect you do want to paint with the
biggest brush you can in order to kind
of stay loose and be more painterly
rather than trying to make it a photo so
I'm going to paint with a very broad
brush and talk in some stereotypes and
some generalities to which almost
everything I say is going to have an
exception to it so the exception might
be your organization it might be your
data scientist
but we're just talking in generalities
um I'm assuming if you're here that you
agree with me about the title of my talk
that ml testing is a garbage fire and
it's rough and it's not good
um and it's It's just tough it's
difficult it's time consuming it's
really hard to get people to do it at
all even if they do it it's really hard
to get them to do it correctly
um and ultimately our applications don't
work or maybe they they work but they're
subtly off
it's just a rough go of it
so as testing is near and dear to my
heart because you know I'm a software
engineer
um this is the culture that I come from
this is the the background of like
building these components that are
really stable
and you know I learned about testing
right off the bat with the auto grader
kind of coming you get me in data
structures and algorithms it's really
baked into the DNA of how I approach
this ml space
and we as like ml engineering and ml Ops
types we love to kind of blow off steam
by criticizing data scientists for how
they do or don't write their code
there's a lot of this kind of stuff out
there if you go looking for it
but really
data scientists don't want to ship crap
we can get into this kind of
antagonistic mindset of like
they're really just out here to make our
jobs really difficult and that's not
true they don't want to ship crap
so why do they keep shipping grep why
does this keep happening
so that kind of brings me to the outline
of this talk which is that testing for
ML applications is a technical problem
and it's a human problem and based on
that human problem it's a different
technical problem if you frame it right
so technical problem
this is probabilistic right especially
when we're talking about core modeling
um you know I'm not a data scientist
this is the kind of model I write uh but
ultimately you're trying to test whether
or not something is the correct answer
when you're doing unit testing kind of
operations and that's really hard when
your code is probabilistic you're not
always going to get the same thing back
so
some technical approaches to that uh
talking about python ecosystem in the
context of like Pi test or something
like that
um you have uh tools like hypothesis uh
you have tools like flaky hypothesis is
a really really good one that doesn't
get a whole lot of air time
it uh helps you throw a bunch of input
data at your unit tests it's kind of a
decorator that you wrap around your
functions and you can build these text
generators or numerical generators and
it'll generate all kinds of gobbledygook
so that you don't have to sit through
sit there and think through all your
edge cases
also have some cool features where like
if it fails on one specific value it'll
hang on to that value so that next time
you run it you're like you hit that
again even though most of the time it's
generating a little bit randomly
so hypothesis very cool highly recommend
flaky decorators you wrap it in like at
flaky and give it some definitions of
like if it fails run it three more times
and if it passes one of those good
enough
so
that's all great like stuff that we can
plug into Pi test cool
um
there really doesn't get to the core of
our problems right
because when we're talking about machine
learning we're dealing with these
absolutely massive systems
and a lot of hardware issues
um
it's a pet peeve of mine that we talk
about these machine learning libraries
especially heavy ones like pytorch and
tensorflow as though they're portable
and they're just not
especially if you're trying to do GPU
integration the requirements for these
the tertiary dependencies the hardware
specifications go really deep
so they're really not portable you can't
just throw them around in places
um
and then you get down to usability
issues like well how do I plug in pi
test to a notebook that's not like the
iteration cycle that this was built for
I mean you can do it but that's not what
it was built for
so that kind of brings us to the fact
that this yeah we can talk technical
problems about testing probabilistic
code but really this whole ecosystem is
more of a human problem
um
and people are talking about this human
problem to be sure
so this is from an interview study uh
where
collect people's opinions and format it
in law Tech it becomes research
um
so just to read this quote directly I
used to see a lot of people complaining
that model developers don't follow
software engineering practices at this
point I'm feeling more convinced that
they don't follow software engineering
practices not because they're lazy but
because software engineering practices
are contrary to the agility of analysis
and exploration
that really rang true for me hopefully
it rings true for you
so
that if we kind of Zoom back out we have
to ask the question why do we test
so let's take this through each of the
kind of the personas involved and answer
that question piecewise
um
so as an engineer we test because it's
in our DNA
because solid Brits equals solid
buildings because the auto grader is
going to come get you because this is
what you're supposed to do
this is how you ensure software quality
this is how we you know make sure that
we're not shipping garbage this is why
you test isn't that obvious
and then we throw it over to a data
scientist who says oh well we test
because you know results might look okay
but they might not be okay and we do a
lot of Statistics to evaluate it and you
know uh we're more worried about people
criticizing our math uh and it's it's a
mindset shift so they're still thinking
about quality and testing but it's
coming from a different place
and then you throw it over to a c-suite
type
and they're saying we test because it's
about business value we test because
outages matter to our customers
and we enforce this by just
providing the right incentives to our
direct reports
so it's not a solid answer about why do
we test and as engineering types zooming
out and thinking about the perspectives
of others kind of puts a different cast
on it
and that kind of reframing brings us
into a place where this is a different
technical problem
we get really hung up on unit testing
and kind of you know we gotta run Pi
tests and we got to have chess and CI
and we got to have this very specific
software engineering driven cycle
and I would argue that we are confusing
the means with the purpose
if we get stuck on on
testing in a software engineering
specific definition we are missing the
forest for the trees
so I want to talk about some other ways
that we can pursue quality and good
testing besides that kind of very rigid
software engineering perspective
so
um
we can talk about data reliability
engineering different environments
observability and where unit testing
still has a place so data reliability
engineering
um
this is a place where we are taking the
principles of SRE site reliability
engineering and applying them to the
data space there is a really excellent
talk on this last year by Igor from big
eye that I highly recommend you go look
up
so these principles of SRE are stuff
like
embracing risk monitoring everything
using Automation and data reliability
engineering is about taking those
principles and applying it to our data
streams
so by embracing risk we say
this is a crazy crazy uh kind of
pipeline that we work with data
processing has a lot more to do with
like
mineral processing than it does with web
development because you know you're
going to get some ore into your mineral
processing and it's going to have
different percentages of the thing
you're looking for and uh you know
somebody already said this morning
garbage in garbage out
so by applying data reliability
engineering practices we are
we are putting data in its proper place
of you know staying suspicious of it
um further we're also putting data in
the proper place that we all talk about
all the time
so
how many of you have heard oh data
science has been the majority of their
time doing data cleaning
have you heard that
I've heard that a hundred thousand times
but we don't act like it when it comes
to testing
when it comes to testing we talk about
code and we talk about functions and all
this we're not talking about the input
and the output data which is what this
whole deal is all about
so I've been really encouraged to see
more people talking about this about
bringing in these Frameworks and really
putting data in the center of our
operations rather than our code
um
for pre-prod environments
uh this is perhaps a little specific to
the environment that I'm working in at
Intuit MailChimp perhaps this applies to
you
but we have this issue where because
these environments to run these models
are so specific
it's really really hard even in these
days of you know Docker and all this
stuff that was supposed to solve the it
works on my machine problem we still get
to oh but it worked in Dev or well in
order to really see how that's going to
go you got to run that abroad you gotta
test in
production is the industry term for that
you can take that with you
um
so
what I would argue for is really leaning
into the idea of pre-production
environments you might call this staging
you might call it pre-prod but
essentially embracing the idea that
for these end-to-end Pipelines
it is a waste of time to try to build
really intricate mocking mechanisms for
each of these different systems involved
and it's way more useful to our
customers data scientists and to us as
people who are looking at the business
to just build a prod-like environment
that's contained and that's not being
shipped out
so that way we can inspect each part
part of this system and put some
automation around it that's prod like in
the same kind of automation that we're
going to put in prod when it really
matters
the environmental issue is
I don't know something I've run up
against a whole lot and maybe I'll have
two about you know managing
well we do our development locally on
you know M1 Max on Docker containers
that have to do this weird loading and
then the containers end up being built
on
you know arm 64 uh instructions and you
try to ship it up to gcp and now it's on
uh x86 instructions and it done work
uh and now we gotta go test it in prod
because of all this stuff so um
it's a much bigger and much more like
fundamental infrastructure issue that
I've come across it's like how do we
actually
provide these safe environments this
comes down to how you manage your
um project instances and Cloud providers
how do you manage environment variables
that might have a little subtle
switching between Dev and stage and prod
um these are these traffic come down to
operational issues right this is like
devops stuff but it's really important
in order to empower our data scientists
to really see what is happening
um and speaking of seeing what is
happening
ML observability and y'all have heard a
lot of stuff about this I'm not going to
go deep into it but just
this is acknowledging the fact that
models can fail in ways that don't
necessarily show up as failures this is
drift detection this is uh
again thinking about uh all of this
machine learning and data processing
like uh manufacturing where you're
you've got Junk that's coming in you
have to evaluate it as it's coming in
um ml observability paired with data
reliability engineering really pushes
you towards that just like holistic uh
systemic evaluation
um another one that I want to talk about
is the production Readiness score
so this is this is a business concept
this is
taking how we talk about models and kind
of flipping it a little bit to say these
models are business assets
unless you're in Academia and then their
research assets but I'm coming from a
business perspective so these are
business assets we spend a lot of time
and a lot of effort pouring energy into
building these models
and we need to treat them like they've
had a lot of energy and time and effort
poured into them we need to invest in
them and we need to treat them like the
assets that they are
one way of doing that is the production
Readiness score
so this is an acknowledgment that stuff
that goes to production especially in
this modeling area
just because it's improv doesn't mean
it's ready for prod
um
especially you know and that might be
because we have some models that are
internal and they have latter standards
or you know there's all kinds of reasons
for that
um so when you do a production writing a
store there's lots of different ways you
could do this but this is about
evaluating kind of those human elements
of what's going on here so your score
goes up if you have documentation your
score goes up if you have ml
observability set up your score goes up
for governance and even I've seen
ethical compliance
so you can do this kind of as a
numerical grade I've also seen this done
very effectively as like a stoplight
system so you might have three major
categories like
code quality
um documentation quality and governance
compliance and you get like a red light
yellow light green light for each of
those
um which can be a little bit more
intuitive than trying to be hyper
specific about like a number and have
you know whenever you put a number to
something they're data scientists are
going to optimize the function right so
find the lowest effort path to get the
number to go up so you know
red light green light yellow light that
that can be a little bit more intuitive
um
as a hot take coming live from me
I think data scientists should be on
call
because we are talking about in for this
whole testing thing we're talking about
enforcing quality right
so it's weird that in this ecosystem we
you know again not every business not
every data science department but a lot
of businesses and a lot of data science
departments you have like the data
scientists writing the code and the
other people who are on call for it
and that is a recipe for mismatched
incentives
because if you're writing it and you're
not experiencing the pain of one that
goes wrong
then your net you don't have an
incentive to build on that you also
don't have an incentive if it's not
coming down from on to high
none of what I'm talking about matters
if your c-suite is not invested in
quality for data science
if they're invested in velocity and not
quality good luck with any of this
seriously these are human problems we
can talk about
Pi test and all that but it is
incentives top to bottom that really
make a difference for
getting good stuff out the door
so ultimately
velocity comes from good tools and a lot
of what we're talking about at this
conference is some good tools
but quality comes from good incentives
so you can't tool your way out of that
you can TR like something like a
production writing a score dashboard
gives you a communication tool to try to
get to those incentives but you've got
to have incentives that come down from
on high
so it kind of gets us to this place of
talking about all those corporate values
and you know I went to art school before
I was in technology and I'm just very
suspicious of all these corporate values
um they just feel like putting a shiny
they feel purposeless they feel like
you're putting the shiny wrapper on
stuff but like no seriously I'm kind of
talking about some corporate value stuff
right here like collaboration so
we get to better ml reliability through
understanding data scientists as our
customer through kind of customer
Obsession we get there by prioritizing
their needs over our software
engineering dogma and finding ways to
work together
um we get there by focusing on bigger
picture inputs and outputs through data
reliability engineering through ml
observability all that stuff and
aligning our incentives talk top to
bottom so I I kind of put this talk
together and then was like
oh gosh that's like corporate value
stuff isn't it but it's like it's kind
of true
um
so it looks like uh I might be the only
talk this morning that's going under
time instead of overtime we're kind of
reaching towards the end here
um
which is good we're all headed to lunch
uh so kind of wrapping up here we
extinguish the garbage fire of ml
testing or at least reduce it to more of
a burning smolder
by not focusing on testing by
reorienting our thinking into something
that's bigger picture
um and by making really dumb memes about
it
so that's what I got for you today thank
you for sticking with me through a
testing talk
[Music]